curators food purveyors you can find it
all at Market in the alley and it is
back this weekend and here to tell us
more is founder and curator Jen taller
welcome back Jay thank you thank you for
having me Mark it in the alley so much
fun tell everyone exactly what this is
and how did you come up with it yeah so
it's been five years in the making so
it's been really awesome to have this
event monthly in our city and it's all
about supporting and highlighting our
local Artisans creatives and giving them
that platform that they deserve and who
knew that there was so much talent in
the in the Vegas Valley and and Beyond
because they all come here and you we're
talking everything from jewelry to
handmade Pottery things like that yeah
it's really awesome you really can find
kind of anything for any style any type
of category like you said textiles
jewelry candles Apothecary uh pets
children it's kind of just a blanket of
a lot of things but really to like the
quality the talent the experience is
really amazing it's a total Vibe when
you go down there so much fun and it's
not just to buy things you can also grab
a bite down there that's a lot of good
food to be had yeah we have great food
trucks desserts all kinds of stuff we're
in the heart of the Arts District this
Sunday so you have all the food and
beverage that's surrounding the uh
Market in the alley and yeah it's just a
great time to go out with friends family
solo and enjoy it now tell us a little
bit about the experience so where
exactly in the heart Arts District is it
local yeah absolutely so it's Imperial
and Main Street those are the cross
streets there's a huge lot there and a
lot across the street so those are the
two main ones and then you have a lot of
amazing shops actually off of Commerce
that are now open so we kind of open all
of our garage doors as well to add to it
let's talk about some of the items I
mean there's so many on here something
that really grabbed my eye was this
jewelry right here just beautiful rings
can we talk a little bit absolutely so
this is a brand American metalsmith a
silversmith here in town we actually
have quite a few amazing talented ones
so you'll see a few this week weekend
showcasing their art and their jewelry
necklaces and everything as well oh
that's so cute and then let's talk about
some of those we've got um another one
of my kind of newer favorite ones is
kindred spirit she has vintage cocktail
Wares and so her whole thing is around
vintage cocktail wears and cocktail
recipes so she's got this really cool
very Niche product line that you can
find to kind of add to your house now
this if you can't make it this weekend
you actually have another option for a
different part of town tell us a little
bit about the we expanded at the end of
last year so we do the third Sunday of
the month in the arts district and the
first Sunday of the month in a new
location in the southwest called the
uncommons what a fun place the uncommons
is if you haven't been there it's just
off of the 215 and South Durango right
yes and so you set up this same thing
down there yeah so they have like the
street that kind of goes around so
there's this back part and then around
the courtyard where they have Earth
cafes open the Speakeasy candle bar is
amazing so it's really cool to integrate
into their develop movement and that
side of town how did you go to come up
with this idea I mean naturally I've
always been someone to go find local
stores makers Artisans flea markets
whatever it may be in my travels so when
I had the opportunity five years ago to
start this I was like yes you brought
them all together and we thank you for
that it's absolutely incredible do not
miss Market in the alley it is such a
fun event and it's all happening this
weekend you can go check it out uh